[Musique]
est ce qu'on a ici c'est un
stérilisateur un peu comme votre resto à
la mer pour ça nous concerne c'est ce
qu'on voit utilise la température peut
monter beaucoup plus haut que 100 degrés
quel point d'ébullition de l'eau et par
transfert de température la mise en
conserves de tomates
un procédé qui permet depuis longtemps
de consommer des tomates partout dans le
monde d'ailleurs on en mange près de 6
kg par personne par année un marché qui
s'est accélérée au 19e siècle entre
autres grâce à l'immigration italienne
en amérique vous êtes présentement
l'épicerie milano qui est techniquement
la première épicerie italienne qu'on a
trouvé ici c'est le cas de l'ex italie
on note yvan de la ccir de la calabre et
de campo basso toutes les tomates
différentes qu un goût différent on au
sittomat canadien qui vient locales et
on a aussi ce qui mène la californie
etats unis
alors la variété et les là c'est
vraiment une question de découvrir celle
qui est bon pour votre palais avec tout
ce choix est peut-être difficile de s'y
retrouver
nous avons demandé à stéphanie côté
nutritionniste d'analyser l'offre pour
elle plus que la valeur nutritive
l'origine prend aujourd'hui toute son
importance pour choisir des tomates en
conserve c'est même pas la valeur
nutritive qu'il faut regarder en premier
mais la provenance
parce que les tomates il y en a qui
proviennent du canada y en a qui
proviennent des états unis dé l'italie
met énormément proviennent de chine et
la production des tomates en chine vient
avec certains tout questionnement d'un
point de vue éthique les conditions de
vie des travailleurs la bosse c'est très
très questionnable les conditions de
culture on peut se poser des questions
également
en effet dans l' empire de l'or rouge
une enquête du journaliste jean baptiste
mallet on montrait le côté sombre de la
tomate les tomates chinoise cultivés
dans des conditions difficiles et qui se
glissent sous forme de purée dans les
conserves de différentes marques sans
mention aucune pour plusieurs concerts
en épicerie lit parfois difficile de
connaître la traçabilité
mais quand vous voyez c'est le ici vous
avez le développer dessus alors celle où
vous assure que c'est des produits qui
viennent un terroir contrôler des
tomates italiennes pas dit cette passe
de mettre d'automates à l'intérieur et
je veux qu'elle vienne soit du canada
soit d'italie soit des états unis j'ai
privilégié du canada bien sûr pour
vérifier c'est un produit vient du
canada
il ne suffit pas de chercher le mot
canada sur la porte par exemple des
sans-voix canada de choix avec ça c'est
une question de qualité
ici on voit fabriqués au canada mais ça
peut vouloir dire que les tomates ont
été mis en boîte au canada pour s'en
assurer on doit voir produit du canada
ça nous assure que les tomates qui sont
à l'intérieur ont vraiment été cultivés
et c'est au pays
si on veut des tomates italiennes le
fait en italie préparer en italie ça ne
veut pas dire qu'elles proviennent
d'italie faut vraiment rechercher un
100% italienne
on fait attention et beaucoup de
marketing souvent derrière la mise en
pratique est des fois on voit le drapeau
l'italie partout
le chef pascal vas-y nous aide à voir
plus clair mais ça c'est un produit qui
a encore son niveau marketing
l'étiquette c'est magnifique c'est beau
la couleur les tomates le nom mais ce
produit qui viennent et des états unis
produite à l'est la california et sa
fille très très bon
mais c'est pas un produit
l'italien l'autre critère de choix le
sodium un point positif de plus en plus
de marques proposent des tomates sans
sel mais il ya beaucoup de variantes et
même au sein d'une même marque
étonnant de voir les versions italienne
toujours moins salée et si cette tomate
italienne le fc lyon 1 125 mg de sodium
je prends une automate
par exemple dans la même marque et ses
tomates entières mais qui nous dit que
c'est un produit du canada ont ni avec 3
150 mg de sodium
donc c'est beaucoup plus sali le sodium
un majoritairement dans le cas de la
tomate c'est principalement une question
de savoir où encore on veut un
standardiser le produit d'année en année
donc si on met du sel ont une perception
salaires embauches la variété de tomate
la saison le cultivar ou la période de
l'année qu'elle a été récoltée est
transformé vont être plus uniforme le
cerveau comme camoufler son petit peu
cette petite variable
car il existe des milliers de variétés
de tomates le plus souvent la tomate
utiliser et de forme allongée avec une
chair épaisse
on l'appelle la tomate italien tomates
italiennes taux de pulpe très élevé 65 %
comparé à l'eau ou peu pain 35 pour ça
alors que les tomates en conserves connu
ici ce prêt seulement la grosse tomate
la tomate rouge qui elle est à peu près
55 ans donc la quantité d'eau est
beaucoup moindre
dans la tomate italienne ce qui pourrait
expliquer qu'on est moins de sel ajouté
parce que là ça va déjà plus présent une
autre différence qui est frappante c'est
la fermeté la tomate canadienne elle est
beaucoup plus ferme
la tomate italienne ma fourche et trompe
tout seul dans la tomate c'est entendre
et c'est là que je vois les faits des
additifs dont classe est strict et là le
chlorure de calcium qui viennent on
s'allonge sur la couleur mais sur la
fermeté de la tomate la majorité des
conserves nord-américaine contiennent
ces additifs soit pour une question
d'innocuité ou encore de textures et d'
équilibre tout comme l'ajout de jus de
tomate ou de pury alors c'est sûr que
dans une étude sur les tomates
disponibles sur le marché
il doit y avoir à peu près toutes les
possibilités de celle de ph d'acide
citrique ou non d'un jus de tomate
ajoutée ou non encore la fonction du
pourcentage de pulpe versus le
pourcentage d'eau à l'intérieur de
l'atome quant aux vitamines l'impact de
la chaleur ont détruit certaines sauf le
lycopène
loomis d'un traitement à la chaleur très
intense qu'on me sens conserve à icc
c'est sûr qu'on perd certaines vitamines
mais par contre que certains nutriments
qui sont augmentés ou du moins qui
deviennent plus disponible et là je
pense notamment au lit copine qui est un
antioxydant très très présent dans la
tomate donc là permettent en conserve
reste un aliment qui étrenne au sein des
produits similaires mais de grandes
différences de goût de textures et aussi
de prix jusqu'à six dollars la conserve
mais c'est pas nécessairement parce que
le produit coûte plus cher qui va me
plaire plus en bouche alors ça dépend
des consommateurs la question de savoir
c'est une chose qui est très personnel
les tomates en conserves ont leur place
et vont toujours avoir leur place quand
on fait une sauce à spaghetti ou un
chili on y va avec la tomate en conserve
et je pense pas qu'elles vont
disparaître
[Musique]